look at this stuff isn't it neat
wouldn't you think my collection's
complete wouldn't you think of the girl
the girl who has
everything
look at this Trove Treasures Untold how
many wonders can one Cavern hold looking
around here you think sure
she's got everything
I've got gadgets and gizmos a plenty
I've got who's it's and what's its
Galore
one thing in the Box
I got 20.
but who cares
no big deal
I want more
[Music]
I Wanna Be where the people are
I wanna see wanna see them dancing
walking around on those what do you call
them
oh feet
flipping your fins you don't get too far
legs are required for jumping dancing
strolling along down up what's that word
again
Street
up where they walk up where they run up
where they stay all day in the sun
wandering free wish I could be part of
that world
thank you